(heart thumping music)
- Three, two--
- One!
(cheering)
- [Woman] Coming up.
(adventurous music)
- [Narrator] Man kind and the elements.
For some, it's an uncomfortable bond.
- [Man] It's getting worse out here guys!
- [Narrator] For others,
when weather strikes, inspiration begins.
- [Man] You come to a place like this
the stars just burst.
- [Narrator] These are the people
who challenge nature,
seek out its limits,
reveal its secrets and
embrace its awesome power.
- Woo hoo!
- [Narrator] In this episode we'll meet
a group of civilians
putting their lives at risk
to rescue people trapped in
Iceland's extreme environments.
- [Man] When you get cooled down
your heart goes pumping
almost out of your chest.
- [Narrator] A man who
climbs hundreds of feet
in the air in the hopes of protecting
some of the oldest trees on earth.
And a team of sailors racing up
the treacherous coastline
of the Pacific Northwest.
(radio chatter)
- Yeah, we're really scared.
- [Narrator] These pioneers
of the great outdoors ahead,
on That's Amazing.
(bouncy energetic music)
- The moment right before I jump
(slow breathing)
there's a split second there
where everything goes completely silent.
And that's when I push off the edge.
Three, two, one, see ya!
(adventurous music)
Woo hoo!
- [Narrator] We have all wanted to fly,
but who would willingly throw
themselves off a mountain?
- [Ellen Voiceover] My
name is Ellen Brennan,
and I'm a wingsuit base jumper.
Currently I'm the fastest
flying woman in the world
when it comes to wingsuit base jumping.
- [Narrator] A wingsuit is a special suit
that inflates with air
and allows you to, in
essence, fly or glide.
Ellen does this all over
the world at crazy speeds.
- [Ellen] On average, I'm flying
about 180, 190 kilometers per hour.
- [Narrator] That's
almost 120 miles an hour.
- [Ellen] So when I'm
going to go do a jump,
I'm focusing on what's
happening weather wise.
I'm looking at the trees to
see if there's wind blowing,
I'm watching the sun to see
if it's heating up the air.
I don't want to push my
luck with the mountain.
My vision is the first thing I notice
so everything becomes very focused
on just my feet.
(slow cracking sound)
(metronome ticking)
my heart's beating
super fast, usually beating
like 160, 170 beats per minute.
Sometimes people will talk to
me and I won't even hear them.
And as soon as I push off I can hear
the splits of my feet off the rocks.
(wind breezing past)
(adventurous music)
Woo hoo!
Like it's something that shouldn't happen.
It's not natural, but I'm doing it.
How in the world did I
get to be able to do that?
It’s one of the coolest things in the world.
Like, I can't think of anything better to do.
(chuckle)
It's pretty mind-blowing.
(frantic music)
- [Narrator] In the dangerous
sees of the Pacific Northwest,
44 sailboats are competing
in one of the longest
and most grueling human
powered races on Earth.
The race to Alaska is a 750 mile journey
and the only way forward
is by wind or by oar.
Here the water and weather conditions
are extremely unpredictable.
If you get stuck in
them, you're on your own.
- [Man] It's getting worse out here guys!
We have to go to Bella Bella.
- I don't think there's any other sport
that relies so heavily
on the weather to propel you.
But you also have to respect it,
otherwise it will destroy you.
- [Narrator] Spencer Weber
is with team Hot Mess.
A crew of four young Canadians
with little endurance sailing experience.
They're racing against faster boats
with more seasoned crews
in a sail contest that knocks out
more than half the teams that attempt it.
So for these intrepid young sailors,
it's not about winning.
It's about making it to the
finish line in one piece.
- Race to Alaska is a 750 mile engineless,
unsupported boat race
from Port Townsend, Washington
to Ketchikan, Alaska.
- And there's only two
checkpoints in between.
You have to go through Seymour Narrows
and you have to go through Bella Bella.
But other than that, it's
choose your own adventure.
- [Jake] The race is really unconventional
because sailing has so many rules.
So we want to strip it all away
and make it just about any boat
no handicaps or anything,
and if you can make it first
you get $10,000.
- There's a lot of different battles
going on in the R2AK.
Fellow racers who you're
trying to compete with,
but you're also trying to overcome
these enormous forces of
nature, wind and current.
And you're just in this tiny little boat
trying to take on these
challenges head on.
- [Narrator] Team Hot Mess
are well aware of the dangers
inherent with sailing in
the Pacific Northwest.
They train for the race
in nearby Vancouver, British Columbia.
- So we had four crew.
It was myself, Neil Roberts,
Will Schwenger, and Nick Schwenger.
We met here and decided
to do the race together.
I was a civil engineer
in the middle of a quarter-life crisis,
and it was between
staying in my cozy cubicle
or going on a suffer fest to Alaska.
So, decided to go to Alaska.
Anyone who tells you they're
doing it for the 10 grand is lying.
Because the guys who are going to win it
are doing it in
hydrofoiling, carbon fiber,
fancy boats and to them 10
grand is just chump change.
For me, I just love sailing
and the R2AK seemed like
the steepest learning curve around.
- [Crowd] Five, four, three, two, one!
(cheering)
- [Spencer] The race started that noon.
Everyone sprinting down
the docks to their boat,
jumping on the boat, untying it,
and then everyone's using
their human propulsion method
to get out of the harbor.
So everyone's rowing and
pedaling and paddling
as quickly as they can to get out.
The adrenaline's going and
everyone's super stoked
and the atmosphere is just wild.
- [Man] Sails are up around the corner.
- [Man] We're finally
reaching the left, boys.
- [Spencer] Rounded the point
out of Victoria Harbor there.
Was awesome wind.
- [Man] All right, first transition zone.
Oh yeah, we're sailing out.
(seagulls squawking)
(intense music)
- When you get further north,
you have a great deal of current.
That wind against tide condition
can cause standing waves.
It will be very difficult
for these vessels
to try and get through
that area of the coast.
- [Spencer] As soon as
we rounded Chatham Point
and entered Johnstone
Strait, the gales picked up.
We had like 35 knots on the nose
and we're like bashing through
all these standing waves.
And we have a pretty light boat
so we were some hang time off waves.
It was making all kinds of crazy sounds.
And then once you get
through the Johnstone Strait,
you're going up the outside of BC.
Then you're in open ocean
and that presents its own challenges.
Lots of swells and no shelter from wind.
And you feel so alone.
It's really humbling,
especially when a storm
starts ripping through.
- [Woman over radio]
Gale warning in effect.
Wind now 1.25 knots
increasing to south two five
- [Man] That's our net expense.
- [Man] Good.
- [Spencer] The forecast
was for 35 to 40 knots
(radio chatter in background)
and we were seeing
like maybe five to like seven knots.
We didn't listen to the weather forecast
and just got slammed by 35 knots of wind.
- [Man] It's getting worse out here, guys!
- Yeah, we're really scared right now
so we turned around.
And now we're trying
to find somebody’s dock or something.
But nobody lives here so
there's not a lot of docks.
- [Spencer] It was
driving rain, big waves,
and you couldn't see your hand
in front of your face it was so dark.
There were no lights on land,
you had no idea where anything was.
We couldn't anchor because
we brought insufficient anchor gear.
So we just had to like keep sailing
around in circles until
daylight basically.
(relieving music)
(sigh)
Getting caught that night before
was a bit of an eye opener.
from there on we kind of like
took the forecasts a lot more seriously.
We mapped out a bunch of bail out points
so if we'd have to stop
we knew on the map like where we could go.
(intense music)
- [Man] Coming in to Ketchikan.
- [Man] Where are they going?
- Oh my god.
- [Cameraman] Looking
forward to being dry?
- Hell yeah.
- [Spencer] You know,
we’ve been in our dry suits
for 24 hours straight.
Everyone's wet and cold and tired.
And then the wind just
completely shut off.
You're paddling into the finish line
of this epic race that you've just done.
It was super anticlimactic,
but the race isn't about the money
and it's not about the finish line;
it's about the journey.
There couldn't be a more poetic
end to the race to Alaska
than a brutal hate mission
to the finish line.
(triumphant music)
(cheering and clapping)
I would definitely do the race again.
You kind of need this, like,
blind optimism to get through it.
And the ability to forget
pain and suffering.
(slow curious music)
- [Narrator] On the sandy
shores of the Florida Keys,
sea turtles are laying their eggs.
But a threat is looming
for these gentle creatures.
The Caribbean climate
has becoming increasingly unpredictable.
As rising sea levels cripple the beaches
where these turtles annually nest.
- They come back to their natal beaches,
so animals that were born here
are coming back to this
very little spit of land
in order to lay their own eggs.
If the beach goes away
they may not be as flexible
to use another beach.
(curious music)
- [Narrator] Dr. Kristen Hart
and her team of researchers
are working around the clock
tagging and tracking these turtles
in an effort to protect their future.
- [Kristen] They're
imperiled, they do need help,
and we're trying to figure
out where the problems are.
(light music)
We are here on East Key
in Dry Tortugas National Park.
We are about 70 miles west of Key West.
And we're in the Gulf of Mexico.
There are seven islands,
we are on one of the smallest,
but one of the densest
turtle nesting beaches.
Some of them are right
on top of each other,
a foot away from each other.
This is a almost completely marine park
and the turtles come up and
grace us with their presence.
It's pretty amazing to
see these animals up close
and personal with them.
And we get right in there.
Generally sea turtles date back
to the time of the dinosaurs.
So it's two hundred
million years of evolution.
Our study was the first
to really concentrate on
the Dry Tortugas turtles.
Our goals are to try to
determine patterns of movement
and habitat use, to figure
out where they might go.
(curious light music)
All these points are either
sightings or capture points.
11C.
When we first started working here
we realized that we could dip
net juvenile green turtles.
I had done this in the Everglades
and out here the water is much more clear.
We can pursue them in the
flats and shallower areas.
She's coming up!
The bigger turtles out here,
we do what's called rodeo capture,
or also turtle jumping.
They're usually 10 or 15 feet down,
but when they need to come get a breath
they're coming up to the surface
and so that's when the
diver meets them down there.
You basically get your
hands sort of on the rear
and right behind the head
and you get the animal pointed up.
I got him.
It's a team effort.
Once we get them onboard the boat,
we'll do a standard workup
which involves measuring
them, weighing them,
taking blood samples, tissue samples.
There's a lot of questions that we can ask
even just about how healthy they are,
and how healthy then
are the resources that they're using.
(curious light music)
We also fix devices on them
to track their movement.
So we've used acoustic
telemetry, radio telemetry,
and then satellite tracking.
So we're learning a lot
about their movement paths
and their areas of residence.
(elegant music)
They've been around the globe
but they're hardwired to
come back to the very place
where they were born,
to lay their own eggs.
If an animal was born on East Key,
she'll come back to East Key.
She's not gonna go use Loggerhead Key
or one of the other keys here.
We all take turns every 30 minutes
walking about this beach in particular
takes about 10 minutes to walk around.
If they nest, we let them nest
and mark off where the nest
is and then we work her up,
just like the same workup we
would do with a little turtle.
She's corralled in a box
because they can be 400 pounds
and they're very powerful.
They'll do that about every two weeks
during a season.
And when we get recaptures
that's really exciting,
because you know the animal still
survived wherever she went.
- [Narrator] In order for
turtles to lay their eggs,
the conditions have to be just right.
Ideally, they'll encounter high tides,
dark beaches, and warm
sea surface temperatures.
Otherwise, they'll do something
called a false crawl,
in which a turtle will make
their way onto the beach
only to turn back around.
- [Kristen] We don't know
really why they false crawl
but something isn't right.
Maybe they're not feeling contractions,
maybe the conditions just
aren't right at that spot,
maybe they dig and they
hit a piece of coral
or a root or something like that.
(spry music)
- [Narrator] And false crawls
can become more frequent.
Rising sea levels reduce
the amount of available beach space
and rising temperatures
can drastically effect sand temperature.
Studies show that
cooler nest temperatures
produce more males,
while warmer nests
generally produce females.
- With sea level rise
and climate change they're threatened.
I think we're a little more concerned
about their trajectory
of their population.
Because it's generally
not good for the turtle.
(calm music)
We've learned a lot
about these Dry Tortugas turtles,
and it really is valuable to me
to know that they value
the research that we're contributing.
We're answering questions
that are important
that haven't been asked before.
It's definitely demanding, but
at the same time, I think it's
one of the most rewarding
things we could ever do.
There aren't many people allowed
on this little patch of land
so I feel very privileged
to be able to play a role
in figuring these turtles out
and being in this very special place.
(grave music)
(loud eruption)
- [Narrator] Italy's Mount Etna
is one of the most active
volcano's in the world.
It erupts nearly every year,
spewing lava and clouds of ash.
But for Claudio Lanzafame,
the black powder is an untapped adventure.
(scraping rocks)
(light curious music)
- My name is Claudio,
and I scale ski over volcanos.
(light music)
(light electronic music)
It's incredible.
(curious spry music)
- [Narrator] Siggi Rafn Hilmarsson
is an Icelandic baker with
an unconventional oven.
He bakes bread by burying it underground
where it's heated for 24
hours by nearby hot springs.
- It's very common to see
hot springs here in Iceland.
There is constant lava crawling under us.
This lava is heating up water
and this water comes
boiling up on the surface.
We could put it in the oven,
but this is much more fun.
- [Narrator] Iceland is one of
the most volcanic regions in the world.
With 30 active volcanos at any time.
That helps create an
abundance of hot springs,
some with boiling hot water.
And Siggi uses them to his advantage.
He specializes in baking rúgbrauð,
a traditional Icelandic rye bread recipe
that dates back hundreds of years.
- I know for sure that in this village
I can track it down as far as
late 1800 something.
My grandmother taught my
mother how to bake this bread
and my mother taught me.
In the hot spring rye bread recipe
we have rye, flower, sugar,
baking powder, salt, and milk.
We put this in a pot,
we put butter in the pot
then we wrap it with plastic foil
and we put it down
in our hot spring hole for 24 hours.
It's very obvious to see
if the ground is hot or not.
I never use a thermometer.
If I need to check the heat
I just use this one.
Our biggest challenge is rain.
If it rains a lot these holes
that we are using can cool down.
And if they are not hot enough,
obviously the bread does
not bake completely.
(spry music)
Everybody eats our bread,
our visitors, the locals.
Hot spring rye bread has a unique taste
that you don't get from ovens.
The texture of this
bread is quite special.
It's quite heavy, it's
not a typical light bread.
When you show this to
travelers that come to Iceland
and you see their faces,
they go "wow", then you start to think
that this is quite amazing actually.
(energetic music)
- There's lots of amazing
weather phenomenon
happening all over our planet,
but what's going on
outside of our atmosphere?
My name is Leland Melvin,
and as an astronaut I can tell you
weather conditions in space
can be a matter of life and death.
Especially during a space walk.
(elegant music)
When we prepare for a space walk,
we have to be able to deal
with temperatures that range from
positive 250 degrees Fahrenheit in the sun
and minus 250 degrees in the shade.
(elegant beat music)
But in our space suit we have
the ability to withstand
those temperature extremes
because we have visors
that reflect the sun
away from our eyes and
we have heated gloves
as well as a heated suit.
And then we have cooling
that allows us to stay cool
during those temperature extremes.
A solar flare is a sudden
flash of brightness
observed near the suns surface
that emits X-ray and UV radiation.
In space, the radiation
levels can be deadly.
When we're notified of a solar
flare on the space station,
we retreat to what we call the dog house.
This dog house is lined with water bags
that allow us to block the radiation
coming from the sun
before it gets to our bodies.
And that's where we go to
keep from getting exposed
to high energy radiation.
(mysterious music)
As we go further out
into our solar system,
weather events become
more and more extreme.
Jupiter, our solar system’s biggest planet,
also features its most impressive storm,
the Great Red Spot.
The gigantic tempest is
twice as wide as planet Earth
and has winds that reach
up to 400 miles per hour.
It's been swirling over
Jupiter for at least 150 years.
Further out, Neptune features
its own great big storm.
It takes up the planets entire atmosphere.
Neptune is our solar
systems windiest planet,
with wind speeds that can reach
up to 1500 miles per hour.
That's nine times faster
than the strongest winds
ever recorded on earth.
To find the strongest known
winds in our universe,
we have to go well
beyond our solar system.
Astrophysicists at York University
have discovered the
fastest winds ever recorded
near a supermassive black hole.
These wind speeds clock in at
125 million miles per hour.
I hope my crew never gets caught up
in anything like that.
(intense music)
- [Narrator] Known as
the land of fire and ice,
Iceland is an island of extremes
where people wage a relentless
war against the elements.
- It's seriously unpredictable weather.
It's basically like a battle zone
of different high pressure/
low pressure areas.
Anything can happen.
- [Narrator] Dangerous conditions
mean people can find
themselves in serious trouble
and in need of rescue.
But there's a problem,
the small country has no army
or government program to help.
So citizens formed the Icelandic
Search and Rescue Team,
known as ICE-SAR, a
national emergency force.
They're everyday people,
willing to risk their lives to save others
in the worst conditions imaginable.
(wind blowing)
- You're going out in the conditions
when everyone else is
supposed to be inside.
So you have to be a little bit crazy
but in a good way.
(adventurous music)
- ICE-SAR is the community of volunteers
that responds to calls for help
all year around in Iceland.
I think to take part in ICE-SAR
you just have to be willing to put forward
the skills that you have.
I sometimes consider a
rescue team like a village,
you need every kind of person
to make everything work.
- I think it's kind of amazing
because it's all volunteerss.
We have professors, taxi
drivers, carpenters,
plumbers, office workers, just name it.
Men and women.
All kinds of people.
It's very hard to imagine Iceland
without our association and our teams.
(excited music)
- [Narrator] Iceland's
breathtaking landscape
attracts tourists and adventure seekers
from all over the world.
But that beauty can lure people
to a false sense of security.
- Weather conditions can change
faster than anything else.
You can have a sunny day,
and in two minutes it's a storm.
Wind, rain, even snow in the summer time.
- People are just going for a hike
and they're pretty confident
that the mountain that they're going on
is not dangerous.
They have the lower glaciers
which have become quite a
popular tourist attraction.
And people are going for walks on these
and they are full of crevasses,
extremely dangerous, super slippery.
And then they fall over
and hurt themselves.
Then they have to rely
on Search and Rescue
to come and find them.
- [Narrator] For average citizens
to gain the skills needed
to be part of ICE-SAR,
they go through a rigorous
18 month training program.
They learn mountaineering,
climbing, and orienteering.
- It takes a huge skillset,
but when you can deal with any weather,
then you can go out and help people.
(sombre music)
- Across the country I think our teams
get 4-5 callers per day.
And our people, they're
running from their own work
or their family to join the team.
- When I get called out,
we have three codes.
It's F1 - high priority, life at stake.
F2 - not as high priority.
And F3 - easygoing.
When you get called out, high priority,
and you get your text
and it says a child,
then your heart goes pumping
almost out of your chest and you run out.
I don't even say goodbye
to my children or wife.
(heroic music)
I can remember one call, a boy,
got lost in Selfoss.
All I could think about was my son.
If he got lost I would like
to have everyone helping.
So a lot of emotions comes
up when you get called up.
(radio chatter)
(hopeful music)
- I'm proud of the unity
and the fact that people
are willing to sacrifice
their spare time to help others.
- The feeling that I get
when we rescue someone.
It doesn't have to be me
that finds the person,
can be another group
searching somewhere else
but we're searching for the same person.
When someone gets found, you
get this wellness feeling,
we did something right.
- They are our heroes in so many ways.
But in Icelandic culture we
don't do a lot of hero talk.
- No, I'm not a hero.
I'm just a part of a team.
- I'm not a hero, no.
I'm just a normal person.
- [Jon Svanberg] I'm very
proud of the association
and what they have accomplished.
They've saved a lot of lives.
(elegant music)
- [Narrator] California's iconic sequoia's
are the largest trees on earth.
These giants have lived
for thousands of years
surviving war, famine and
the rise of globalization.
But California's ongoing
drought could mean disaster.
These enormous trees are already
showing signs of weakness
never seen before.
Anthony Ambrose, and
a team of researchers,
are heading into the forest
to climb hundreds of feet in the air
and see what can be done to
save these magnificent trees.
(heroic music)
(lighthearted music)
- Sequoia National Park
is just absolutely amazing.
A giant sequoia is the
largest tree on the planet.
And they have these huge orange trunks
and massive sprawling crowns
that have huge limbs.
Some of the branches are
five, six feet thick.
They live to be more than
three thousand years old.
I'm fascinated with how they grow
and how they are able to
get to be so old and so big.
It's just an amazing experience
to be able to study them so
intimately and so closely.
California's currently in the
middle of a severe drought.
The giant sequoia trees
appear to be showing
some symptoms of some drought stress.
More stress than we've ever
measured in giant sequoia trees
and we want to know why.
(adventurous music)
Our research entails climbing
the giant sequoia trees
and measuring their water status basically
an index of how stressed they are
relative to the environment.
The water status of all plants
is kind of like the equivalent
of blood pressure in a human.
It's just a basic measure of
how much water they have available to them
to continue to function and grow.
So we clip little shoots of foliage
and put 'em in this device
that is able to measure how much tension
the water column is at at the time
that you cut that little piece of foliage.
We put the little piece of foliage,
leaf end down, into this
pressurized chamber.
And the amount of pressure it takes
to push the water back out of the stem
is equal to the amount
of tension it was under
when you cut that piece of foliage.
When water availability declines,
such as during a drought,
that creates a lot more
tension in the tree.
When the tension becomes too great
then tiny little air
bubbles form in the wood.
And when it gets bad enough
then the plant suffers and starts to die.
(concerned music)
- There's a couple reasons
why we need to climb to
the tops of these trees.
(hopeful music)
As water moves up the tree,
it's fighting gravity and friction.
And the top of the tree is gonna be
the most stressed part of the tree.
So in order to get a really good idea
of how stressed they are,
we need to go to the very tippy top.
It's a really humbling experience
because you're up in the crown
of these massive ancient things.
And they make you feel small.
I'm at the top of a very
large giant sequoia tree.
We're waiting for the sunrise
because it's really,
really pretty this morning.
In order to get a really
good understanding
of how the trees are
responding to the drought
we need to understand
different time periods.
We climb up into the giant sequoia trees
at predawn hours before the sun rises
and measure their water status
kind of at their most relaxed state
when they're not losing
water to the atmosphere.
And then we also go back
in the middle of the day
when they're the most
active and most stressed
and measure their water status
and collect leaf samples
at that point as well.
(hopeful music)
Giant sequoias really need fire,
it's a natural part of the ecosystem here.
They can use this information
to prioritize where they
do prescribed burning
to be able to thin out some
of the understory trees
that are competing for the water
and hopefully provide more water
to the giant sequoia trees.
It's important to realize and remember
that these trees have been
living for thousands of years
and they've dealt with
pretty severe events,
fires and droughts, in the past.
And they're amazingly resilient.
One of the things that really
is remarkable about these trees
is their ability to recover
from drought type events.
The question is, as conditions change,
as temperatures continue
to increase globally,
are conditions gonna change to a point
where they may reach some threshold
where they're not able to recover
from these type of events?
It's an absolutely
amazing, unique experience
to be able to climb into these trees.
We wanna preserve them;
we want them to be here;
and we want them to be healthy and happy.
(adventurous music)
- [Narrator] It's a
surprisingly dangerous mission,
safely navigate the skies of one
of the iconic tourist
destinations in America.
The helicopter pilots of Niagara Falls
battle extreme wind and
unpredictable weather conditions
all to give tourists that
one spectacular view.
- Sometimes it is very scary,
you not to let the fear overcome you
so you control the aircraft,
you get it back to a safe environment
so you can go home at night.
That's the name of the
game, go home. (chuckle)
(flowing and crashing water)
(hopeful music)
My name's Stanley Snopkowski.
I've been flying over Niagara falls
about 20 years, and each day is different.
I spent 20 years in the military.
I've flown in Germany, England, Vietnam,
and the weather here is
nothing like anything else.
(anxious music)
(helicopter blades whirling)
Niagara Falls is a beautiful,
but like anything beautiful
there's a ugly side to it.
The weather here can change quite rapidly.
You can have snow showers
and five minutes later
you can have bright sunny blue skies.
You have to have a healthy respect for it
because it can go wrong
in a matter of minutes.
The winds can gust up to
30 to 40 miles an hour.
When the wind comes around the buildings
it tends to create mechanical turbulence,
either an updraft or
downdraft or swirling.
And then sometimes when you
make the turn into the wind
it's almost sometimes
like hitting a brick wall.
I've had instances where
the aircraft wanted to come apart,
quit flying and we
nursed it to the ground,
we got down and we walked away.
And it could have ended up differently
without the training,
without the knowledge.
(chuckling)
(sombre music)
As the only pilot onboard the aircraft,
if something happens
it's my responsibility
to get everybody down safely.
I don't like being
scared in the helicopter.
I'm not a thrill seeker,
I don't take a lot of unnecessary chances.
I have a skill, I have knowledge,
I know my aircraft and
I know my capabilities
and I try not to exceed those.
I sometimes think that Mother Nature
is not my friend today
because of the winds or
because of the rain or snow.
You deal with that.
You hopefully come out on the good end.
Or the other thing is
is you just sit there and
say, “Okay, you win today.
I'm not gonna fly."
(chuckling)
(adventurous music)
I look at the Falls and I see
the beauty of nature.
Some days just after a
major storm comes through
the air is so clear.
You have maybe a hundred miles visibility.
And it's just awe inspiring
to be able to see all that
and see the falls from a
different angle, I just love it.
(enchanting music)
(elegant music)
- [Narrator] There's a lot to love
about living in a big, bright city.
People, culture, late night food.
But there's something missing.
It's there but you can't see it.
The night sky.
(homely music)
This is the story
about a small town in Colorado.
- Actually, two small towns in Colorado.
- [Narrator] That are devoted to space.
- Westcliffe has a
population of 564 residents,
and Silver Cliff has a population of 575.
This used to be a mining community
and then it evolved into
a railroad community
and then into a ranching community.
We're always looking to do something
that will bring people into our community
and lately that seems to be
we need to invest in our sky.
- [Narrator] So they made
light pollution their enemy.
They darkened their towns
so that the night sky
could become their star attraction.
- Have you ever seen the Milky Way?
That goes from horizon to horizon.
88% of the world's population
has never seen the Milky Way.
It's the most magnificent
thing in the world,
that's what we see here.
- [Narrator] But for the towns to go dark,
they needed to cover all of their lights.
Not just street lamps,
but the lights outside every
house and ranch near town.
- That wasn't easy.
This is a frontier town
and I can tell you,
frontier people don't like
being told what to do.
We had to win their hearts and minds.
- [Narrator] It took 10 years.
They passed ordinances,
raised money to cover the street lights,
and even built an observatory.
The darker the town became,
the more people saw the light.
In 2016, the valley's dark sky
was designated as one of
the darkest in the world,
drawing visitors from all over.
(calm music)
(dialogue drowned out by music)
- [Man] Okay, might need a
six pack of 'em. (chuckles)
(background chatter)
- Well I was really hoping
we'd be able to see Saturn by now.
- Yeah, me too.
- That a community would
decide to dim its lights
and help everyone to appreciate
the beauty of the night
sky is an amazing thing.
- You come to a place like this
and the stars just
burst and it's remarkable.
(calm music)
- Not a lot of people are lucky enough
to see the dark sky as
our ancestors saw it,
and I feel that we're a very special place
to be able to look at the stars
as people did thousands of years ago.
- [Man] It's a humbling thing.
Suddenly, you realize
you can almost touch it
and you're now a part
of the bigger universe.
And so it's just a wonderful experience
to see the dark skies,
and that's what we're trying to preserve.